und sie würde ich auch nur leicht jahren
kann die sonne knödel gruppe auf die
würdigung mit dem anderen zusammen
passen keine partnervermittlung hey
leute was geht ab jetzt willkommen bei
einem neuen video
ich hoffe natürlich euch geht's gut und
es geht ja hier auch drauf mir jetzt
gehört den pulli und der pulli sind
natürlich wie immer in der beschreibung
zweck nahmen und nehmen hier könnt ihr
gerne vorbeischauen
darum geht es halt nicht ich habe mir
das überlegt und zwar stumpf gesagt wir
erwarten heute euren zeugnis
durchschnitt es ist nämlich wieder
soweit in den meisten nähe ich glaube in
polstern gab es zeugnisse sonst bekommt
er jetzt wahrscheinlich diese woche
nächste woche war darüber nicht oder
über über übernächste woche oder über
über über übernächste woche zeugnisse
oder und ich habe euch ob institute
aufgefordert schickt mir gerne mal ein
foto von euch zu und dann erreicht warum
oberflächliches hattest und
oberflächlich zu tun
dann sagen wir einfach was wir denken
was die person 50 durchschnitt hat zum
beispiel bei dir wirklich zu denken ich
würde es sonst ja das ist das video wenn
ihr bock auf auch noch ein partner ist
auf jeden fall jetzt schon mal daumen
nach oben da und wir fangen an
jeder hat sich fünf rausgesucht
verlierer muss sich am ende auszahlen
okay genau so machen wir das so wir ein
bisschen rüber dann können wir hier
immer in der mitte die hier weitermachen
ok schnickschnack wer als erstes wurde
zeigen gehabt also wenn du gewinnst du
mir sagen hatte ich gewinne ich dir
schnick schnack schnuck zu mir sagen
okay dann ist das erste foto das heißt
wenn ich das jetzt ich sag mal so man
darf sich immer um 0,2 verschätzen ok
0,2 nach oben 0,2 nach unten das heißt
wenn jetzt zum beispiel 2,3 hat hätte
ich auf 2,1 102,5 sagen können okay okay
so machen wir das ja also es hängt
natürlich auch immer damit zusammen in
welcher stufe man ist sie zum beispiel
weiß nicht wenn jetzt schon der zehnte
stufe ist es ist ja natürlich schwerer
als wenn man erster klasse ist genau das
gleiche trifft natürlich einen ob man
jetzt auch in asien realschule der
hauptschule oder der gesamtschule oder
was auch immer alles für schulen gibt es
bei ihr würde ich jetzt einfach mal
sagen 2,3 und
bis 23 so dass wir dann schon mal der
erste punkt für mich und jetzt bin ich
mal gespannt wie gut du bist ihr könnt
natürlich auch immer vielleicht mit
raten und mir weitere fotos zukommen was
man ja auch mal bock habt mitzumachen
weiter mit dieser hübschen jungen dame
was würdest du sagen 2,9
wir haben ja gesagt man darf ich mal 0,2
verschätzen und tut mir wirklich sehr
leid auch gerade 30 gefallen
doch parallel fußball dazu leider hat
sich 2,3
das heißt haben kein punkt für dich so
jetzt kann das nächste foto einmal diese
junge dame
das ist natürlich wieder ganz leicht
wir haben hier die sophie 15 jahre alt
geht in die neunte klasse und hat einen
durchschnitt von weil ich würde einfach
mal sagen die sieht aus wie so ein 1,9
im schnitt ich wohne entsprechen und
habe 340 punkte das entspricht ungefähr
einem 1 kann man nur dadurch habe ich
doch gesagt sie wollen in schweden wo
ich habe sogar schwedische zuschauer
das tut mir natürlich sehr leid was da
am sonntag passiert ist nie was haben
wir heute vor allem was da am samstag
passiert ist natürlich bitter wenn man
dann bis zu 95 minuten noch
unentschieden rausgeht und dann in der
minute das 2 2 1 bekommen nicht letztes
irgendwann wird erzählt stehen jetzt
wissen die schweden endlich mal wie das
ist wenn man fast das ganze regale
aufgebaut hat und dann eine schraube
film mehr über dieses kleine tier zu
erfahren gehen wir hinaus auf eine wiese
wo leute ich bin dran und ich würde
sagen wir machen einfach mal weiter mit
einem jungen und zwar habe ich mir hier
supreme baum ausgesucht ich dachte
wirklich eben sein nummernschild wer
wirklich so prima ich glaube das ist nur
drauf photoshop mir was schätze ich mal
das hier ja ok immer noch 1 1
1933 komma nichts gegen dich er sagt was
3,1 3,1 es tut mir wirklich sehr leid
leider entspricht auch diese vermutung
nicht der wahrheit
3,6 da ist auf jeden fall noch luft nach
oben aber okay du bist dran als wir mit
einem punktestand von 10 für mich was
hätte man auch anderes erwarten ich
meine ich kenne michael besonders gut
aus überzeugt ich habe mich damit
letzten schon so stark befasst ich habe
einfach so ein riecher dafür eigentlich
sollte ich lehrer werden aber werde ich
mich weil ich will kein lehrer werden
warum weil ich lange genug in der schule
zeigen wir das nicht so leicht ein
richtig richtig knuffigen das war
eigentlich so richtig aber intensiver
recht wenn er liebsten so komisch das
verspielt werden
ich würde einfach mal sagen aber das ist
schwer
es ist wirklich irgendwie bei den
anderen ist mir sofort das eingefallen
hier könnte es wirklich gut sein aber
ich glaube das ist so ein mittelding 2,5
soll ich was sollen 3,4 durch ja wenn du
mich mal irgendwas ist kam zu mir denn
hier warte mal immer noch 1 0 für mich
ne okay war natürlich hängt ein wo hast
du denn bitte ein punkt gemacht
dadurch zeigt jetzt die nächste oder dem
nächsten jahr wieder ein jugend und zwar
haben wir hier in rausgesucht was wird
zu schätzen da ist das 4 3 2,4 24
das hier sicher nicht noch mal
überdenken ich würde noch mal ein
bisschen irgendein gucken hier so ein
bisschen vielleicht runter oder
rübergeschickt bei 2,24 zugesagt nur 2,3
also ein punkt für dich das heißt wir
haben jetzt einen stand von 12 12
1 ich bin ja auch schon die zeugnisse
von eins zu eins und wie viele haben wir
uns gegenseitig schon gezeigt wie viel
ein was jetzt gingen würde ich schon
gesagt hier jeder 3 okay so das heißt es
kann jetzt noch mal eng werden in den
letzten runden
ich hoffe ihr rad ist auch immer fleißig
mit den nächsten schüler eines leer
institutes das ist dieser junge wird
sind auch knuddeln ja das ist sehr mager
mal und schöne grüße hier auch an dich
nicht dass uns seine lern referenzen zur
seite stellt sorin lehre aufnehmen weil
man dann würde ich jetzt auch er war
seine zweite sportliche 2,9 verboten 3,3
und nein warum sollte so schlecht aber
der hat der kandidat auch den satz nicht
richtig hinbekommt geschrieben mein an
doch ja doch also aber der
notendurchschnitt auseinander na ja doch
er hat es gut gemacht besser als du hast
du nichts hinbekommst der maler und hier
auf jeden fall auch noch david sich
jetzt das nächste schuljahr ordentlich
auf den hintern gesetzt und da wird war
aus der drei fordernde 2 gemacht sag mal
weniger fordert spielen weniger
fortnight spielen mehr lärm mehr lernen
es wäre ein wird das noch was alex jeder
einfach das nach was alex sagt ok wollen
wir meinen schläfe so leute kommen wir
zunächst eine schülerin und zwar haben
wir hier sie ich habe leider den namen
vergessen aber was schätzte die werde
ich auch nur recht ja kann sie so eine
kugel gruppe offen
endlich würde gut mit dem anderen
zusammen passen keine partnervermittlung
denkt sie hat einen notendurchschnitt
von 1,7
so leider muss ich hier auch hier sorgen
dass das nicht der wahrheit entspricht
wir haben ja einmal von dir aufgestellt
eine these und wir haben ja die tatsache
die tatsache ist dass alter von ihr um
die tatsache stimmt nicht überein mit
der these das heißt wer das jetzt eine
deutscharbeit sie hat den schnitt von
1,0 und du lagst voll daneben war habe
ich auch gedacht
ich verstehe das echt nicht 1,9 warum
hast du das gemacht hast du voll weh
schreibt mir mal eure besten schnitt in
die kommentare
und ich habe nein besser in der dritten
klasse oder so 1,2 keinen und da hatte
ich nur zwei nicht ne grundschule so
vielleicht einer fünften klasse 1,8 oder
sowas keine ahnung welche nicht mehr
okay haben wir noch irgendwie in denen
ich hier noch nicht gezeigt ich bin ja
dran also das ist jetzt die letzte womit
das heißt wenn du jetzt den punkt macht
hast du ja aber du hast ja auch
angefangen einfluss an und zwar kommen
wir hier zu dieser hübschen jungen dame
wir haben hier die ich weiß nicht mehr
wie sie heißt irgendwie weiß nicht was
bei km was schätzt du stellen sie bitte
eine these auf und wir schauen ob diese
der tatsachen entspricht
bitte bitte geben sie eine antwort ab in
5 4 3 2 1 2
2,0 da würde ich vielleicht noch mal
drüber nachdenken genauer alex hat die
kopfnuss nächsten zu ertragen
also die polin hat einen löschen von 22
damit steht 2 1 für dich du hast
gewonnen' herzlichen glückwunsch jedoch
kopfschmerz leute das war's mit dem
zeugnis durchschnitt erraten video ich
hoffe natürlich erst hat euch gefallen
falls das der fall war last jetzt schon
mal ein viertel nach oben da schickt mir
gerne wenn ihr euer zeugnis bekommen hab
das ganze zu damit ich mich so ein
bisschen wieder in diese lehre position
einfinden kann mir das eine oder andere
zeugen ist man schauen können dass ein
bisschen analysieren euch den einen oder
anderen tipp mit auf den weg geben
jak/dapd oder instagram könnte auch
werden bei marie vorbeischauen und wir
sehen uns mittwoch wieder kommt mainz
neues video hat rein